हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है?
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही तो प्लीज चैट
में यस या नो बता दीजिए।
सुनाई दे रही है जगत गुरु जी?
ओके
मानस सिंह शर्मा काफी आफ्टर लॉन्ग टाइम
काफी लंबे समय बाद आप दिखाई दिए हो क्लास
में
सब कुछ सही
बताइए सब कुछ सही है।
आज तो मुझे नए-नए चेहरे नए-नए नाम देखने
को मिल रहे हैं। जैसे कि
मैं अच्छा हूं ब्रो। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं।
आई एम फाइन।
ओके। 9 टू 6:45 आपका ऑफिस रहता है। ओके
ओके। चलो तो आज का टॉपिक आपको सबको पता चल
गया होगा कि आज का टॉपिक क्या होने वाला
है क्योंकि जो प्रीवियस क्लास थी जो हमने
संडे को ली थी वो
आपको पता ही है हमने
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक लाइफ साइकिल के
बारे में बात की थी तो उसके हमने तीन फेज
डिस्कस किए थे बाकी के जो चार फेज बच गए
थे वो आज हम डिस्कस करने वाले हैं। तो
आई होप कि प्रीवियस क्लास में आपका कोई
डाउट नहीं है। अगर आपका कोई भी डाउट है
प्रीवियस क्लास से रिलेटेड तो प्लीज आस्क
मी अभी पूछ लीजिए तब तक जो स्टूडेंट्स हैं
उनको ज्वाइन होने दीजिए क्योंकि आज तो
मैंने क्लास लेट स्टार्ट की है फिर भी
स्टूडेंट उतने ही हैं आना पसंद ही नहीं
करते पता नहीं उनको क्या इस सीरीज से डर
लगता है या उनको पता नहीं क्या लग रहा है
कि सीरीज उनके काम की नहीं है। आई डोंट नो
कि मुझे नहीं पता कि आप लोग क्या सोच रहे
हो क्योंकि इतनी लो प्रेजेंस शायद किसी की
नहीं होती। कभी भी नहीं आते आप लोग। पता
नहीं
क्या चल रहा है आप लोगों के दिमाग में या
आप सोच क्या रहे हो। आई डोंट नो कि आप
लोगों को मुझ पर विश्वास नहीं है या इस
सीरीज पर विश्वास नहीं है या इस फ्री इसकी
कॉस्ट फ्री है इसलिए इस पर विश्वास नहीं
है।
इसलिए आप इसको देखना नहीं चाहते। इसलिए आप
लोग यहां पर इसको कवर नहीं करना चाहते। या
जो चीजें इसमें कवर हो रही हैं कि बहुत
सारी चीजें बार-बार आपको
यहां पर देखने को ऐसी चीजें सुनने को मिल
रही हैं। तो आप लोगों को समझ में नहीं आ
रहा कि क्योंकि सारी चीजें आपके लिए
फर्स्ट टाइम है। क्योंकि आप लोग किताबें
नहीं पढ़ते। अह सिर्फ आप अह कुछ
ट्यूटोरियल्स देखते हो या फिर के अह किसी
क्लासेस को ज्वाइन करते हो तो वहां पे जो
बता दिया कि आपको मैंने बता दिया कि टोटल
सात स्टेप होते हैं। वहीं पर जस्ट एक मिनट
में टोटल
सात फेजेस को मैंने एक्सप्लेन कर दिया।
उसके बाद नेक्स्ट मैं मूव करता हूं
नेक्स्ट पेज पर। तो मे बी शायद वो आप
लोगों के लिए सही है। इतनी डिटेल्स आप
लोगों को हजम नहीं होती। आई थिंक कि मुझे
यह लग रहा है तो वैसा भी मैं करवा सकता
हूं और मुझे लगता है शायद मुझे उस पे
शिफ्ट करना पड़ेगा अपने आपको जस्ट आपके
सामने मैं टूल्स लेकर आऊं और टूल्स के
सामने मैं रन करूं तो मे बी दैट विल बी
बेटर एवरीवन
ताकि आप लोग आओ भी गए और सीरीज को अटेंड
भी करोगे शायद यह अच्छा रहेगा आप लोगों के
लिए क्योंकि
मैं आपको डिलीवर क्या करने की कोशिश कर
रहा हूं आप लोग डिलीवर करने की कोशिश कर
रहा हूं कि आपको चीजें सीखने को मिले।
आपको रियलिटी से वाकिफ करवा रहा हूं।
रियलिटी पता है क्या होता है कि सोचो
रियलिटी रियलिटी ही होती है। जैसे कि जो
चीज एक्चुअल में होती है
कैसे करनी चाहिए? सही और गलत के बीच में
फर्क एज ए फेंटेस्टस
डायरेक्ट हर कुछ कर लेंगे हम। हर एक चीज
को परफॉर्म भी कर लेंगे। सब कुछ सीख
लेंगे। बट उन सब चीजों के बारे में हम
कैसे डिस्कस करेंगे जो एक्चुअल में होती
हैं। जैसे कि स्कोप डिस्कस करना या सबको
पता है कि पेन टेस्टिंग में कुछ गिनेचुने
स्टेप होते हैं। रिकॉन है, पोस्ट
एक्सप्लइटेशन, एक्सप्लइटेशन है। तो मुझे
पता है सबका उसमें इंटरेस्ट होता है कि
एक्सप्लइट कर लूं, बाईपास कर लूं।
यह सारी चीजें सबका इंटरेस्ट होता है। बट
उन सब चीजों का क्या कि इस इंटरेस्ट के
अलावा भी क्योंकि यह चीज करने के लिए भी
तो कुछ ना कुछ तो आपके पास होना चाहिए ना।
आपको नॉलेज, आपके अथॉरिटी, आपके स्कोप यह
चीजें भी तो कोई ना कोई तो यूज़ करता होगा
क्योंकि आप एक बिगिनियर हो। आप उस लेवल पे
काम नहीं करते। लेकिन जब आप मे बी ये
अच्छे से बता दे मानस सिंह शर्मा बताइए आप
लोग डायरेक्टली कभी भी आप डिफेंसिव रोल
में हो लेकिन आपके पास कोई भी ऑफेंसिव
वाला बंदा आता है तो
आप बताओ क्या विदाउट स्कोप या विदाउट
प्लानिंग या विदाउट डिस्कशन डायरेक्टली
करने देते हो आप ही बता दीजिए
मैं समझा नहीं क्या बोले हो सर आपको मेरी
वजह से मानसिंह शर्मा चलो मैं क्लास को
स्टार्ट करता हूं फिर ज्यादा टाइम वेस्ट
नहीं करने वाला
चलो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो हम
टॉपिक को कंटिन्यू करने वाले हैं पहले एक
मानसिंह शर्मा की बात को हम पूछ लेते क्या
कह रहे थे आप?
मेरी वजह से कैसे मिली भाई? आपकी मेहनत
है। मैं तो जस्ट एक छोटा सा ट्रेनर हूं जो
आपको ट्रेनिंग देता हूं। मैं बाकी मेहनत
आपकी है
जो आप लोग परफॉर्म करते हो। मैं तो सब
आपको सिर्फ सिखाने वाला हूं। तो चलिए हम
बात करते हैं कि देखो जो प्रीवियस क्लास
थी, लास्ट क्लास थी, हमने क्या सीखा है?
लास्ट क्लास में हमने देख लिया कि जो फेज
वन के बारे में हमने डिस्कस किया स्कोपिंग
फेज क्या होता है? इसको काफी टाइम से हम
डिस्कस किया। फेज टू के बारे में डिस्कस
किया इसमें क्या-क्या होता है और फेज थ्री
के बारे में डिस्कस किया। अब आते हैं हम
इस लाइफ साइकिल के एक और सबसे एक्साइटिंग
फेज पर। दैट इज कॉल्ड इंप्लीमेंटेशन फेज।
दैट इज कॉल्ड इंप्लीमेंटेशन फेज। अभी हम
आते हैं इंप्लीमेंटेशन फेज पर। तो
इंप्लीमेंटेशन फेज में क्या होता है? दिस
इज द फेज वेयर ऑल द प्लानिंग ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस ओसेंट इंटेलिजेंस एंड अप्रूव्ड
प्रिटेक् आर ट्रांसफॉर्म इनू एक्चुअल
ऑपरेशन
मतलब यहां इंप्लीमेंटेशन फेज में क्या
होता है यह वो फज़ है जहां पर आपकी जितनी
भी प्लानिंग है आपका जो भी ओसेंट है ओसेंट
इंटेलिजेंस है जो भी सारा का सारा जो
ओसेंट है या जो आपके अप्रूव्ड प्रिटेक्स्ट
है वह सारे के सारे क्या होते हैं एक
एक्शन में कन्वर्ट हो जाते हैं। एक एक्शन
में ट्रांसफ़ॉर्म कर दिए जाते हैं। मतलब
एक्चुअल ऑपरेशन होता है ना उसमें
ट्रांसफ़ॉर्म होते हैं। मतलब यहां पर आप
क्या करते हो? एग्जीक्यूशन करते हो। इन
अदर वर्ड्स दिस इज़ वेयर द इंगेजमेंट मूव्स
फ्रॉम प्रिपेयर टू एग्जीक्यूशन। मतलब यह
है कि
मतलब यहां पर यह है कि आपकी जो इंगेजमेंट
था अभी तक आपने जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट
की जो रॉ डाटा वैलिडेट किया उसके बाद आपने
अप्रूवल लिया अपने क्लाइंट से उसके बाद आप
एग्जीक्यूशन फेस में एंटर करते हो। मतलब
यह है कि अप्रूवल मिलते ही आपका शुरू होता
है रियल एक्शन। और रियल एक्शन कहां पर
होता है? रियल एक्शन होता है आपका किसके
अंदर?
रियल एक्शन होता है आपका इंप्लीमेंटेशन
फेज के अंदर। इंप्लीमेंटेशन फज़ के अंदर
होता है आपका रियल एक्शन। तो एट दिस स्टेज
द एंटायर बैक एंड इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
रिक्वायर्ड फॉर द असेसमेंट इज़ क्फ़िगरर्ड
एंड वैलिडेटेड बिफोर एनी इंटरेक्शन विद द
टारगेट बिगिंस। मेरे यहां पर कहने का मतलब
क्या है कि इस फेज को परफॉर्म करने के लिए
आप क्या करते हो? अपना पूरा बैक एंड
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर कॉन्फ़िगर करते हो
असेसमेंट के लिए और उसके बाद उस
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को वैलिडेट भी करते हो
एक्चुअल एग्जीक्यूशन से पहले। कहीं आप
ब्लाइंडली उसको एग्जीक्यूट नहीं कर सकते।
पता चला वो काम ही ना करें। तो नाउ
अभी थोड़ा सोच के देखो। अगर फॉर एग्जांपल
अगर आपने किसी को एक फेसिंग ईमेल भेजा अगर
आपने किसी को फेसिंग ईमेल भेजा लाइक अटैकर
123@gmail.com
वुड यू ट्रस्ट इट या आपको लगता है कोई आप
पर ट्रस्ट करेगा? बताइए आप पर कोई ट्रस्ट
करेगा? ऑब्वियसली नहीं करेगा। बिकॉज़ उसको
सीधा पता चल जाएगा कि किसी यह फेसिंग ईमेल
है। दैट इज व्हाई इसलिए हैकर क्या करते
हैं? दैट इज व्हाई व्हाई ड्यूरिंग दिस फज़
अटैकर इन्वेस्ट अटैकर इन्वेस्ट
सिग्निफिकेंट एफर्ट इनू प्रिपेयरिंग द
टेक्निकल इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर बिहाइंड द
ऑपरेशन। इसलिए हैकर क्या करते हैं? इस फेज़
में बहुत सारी टेक्निकल चीजें बैकग्राउंड
में क्या करते हैं? रेडी करते हैं। फॉर
एग्जांपल जैसे लुक अलाइक डोमेन। मतलब लुक
अलाइक डोमेन का मतलब क्या है? लोक अलाइक
डोमेन का मतलब है अटैकर्स ऐसे डोमेन
खरीदते हैं। ऐसे डोमेन रजिस्टर करते हैं
जो ओरिजिनल डोमेन जैसे देखने में लगते
हैं। फॉर एग्जांपल जैसे आप बोल सकते हो
जैसे microsoft.com है उसको आप ऐसे
रजिस्टर कर सकते हो। Apple.com को Apple l
की जगह वन यूज़ कर लिया। अभी इससे फायदा
क्या होता है? क्योंकि जो आपका इंसानी
दिमाग होता है जो आपका मेरा सबका जो
इंसानी दिमाग होता है ह्यूमन माइंड होता
है उसमें क्या होता है कि वो हम हमारी आदत
होती है डायरेक्ट वर्क वर्ड पढ़ने की
डायरेक्ट पूरा वर्ड पढ़ने की हमारी आदत
होती है ना कि एक-एक
लेटर को पढ़ने की हम पूरा वर्ड को पहनते
पढ़ते हैं जैसे apple.com microsoft.com
हम पूरा ध्यान नहीं देते कि जीरो ओ ऐसे
लिखा गया है। क्योंकि यहां तो अब मैंने
हाईलाइट किया इसलिए आपका ध्यान चला गया।
अदरवाइज
यूआरएल में आपका ध्यान नहीं जाता। इसीलिए
क्या होता है? इन्हीं चीजों की वजह से हम
क्या करते हैं? इन पर क्लिक कर देते हैं
ब्लाइंडली और इसी चीज का फायदा उठाया जाता
है सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में या किसी भी अटैक
में। दूसरी हम बात करते हैं इंप्लीमेंटेशन
में वेपनाइज्ड डॉक्यूमेंट्स। मतलब मतलब
क्या है कि हम ऐसे माइक्रो इनेबल्ड
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ऑफिस डॉक्यूमेंट या पीडीएफ
तैयार करते हैं जिसमें हम क्या करते हैं?
कोई बैकडोर छुपा देते हैं। कोई बैक डोर
छुपा देते हैं। और जैसे ही क्या करेगा?
यूजर उसको क्या करेगा? इनेबल करेगा।
क्योंकि डॉक्यूमेंट को ओपन करेगा।
डॉक्यूमेंट को ऊपर करते एक ऊपर आता है ना
इनेबल
लाइक
इनेबल कंटेंट। ऐसे
इनेबल कंटेंट। जैसे ही इनेबल कंटेंट पे उस
पे क्लिक करेगा उस डॉक्यूमेंट को ओपन
करेगा तो बैकग्राउंड में क्या होगा जो
हमारा रिवर्स सेल है बैकग्राउंड में जो
हमारा पेलोड है वो एग्जीक्यूट होगा और जो
रिवर्स सेल है या जो अनऑथराइज्ड कनेक्शन
है वो अटैकर के इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के साथ
क्या हो जाएगा बन जाएगा वो अटैकर के
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के साथ बन जाएगा या फिर
हम बात करें तीसरी चीज मेल
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर अटैकर मे आल्सो कॉन्फ़िगर
देर ओन मेल सर्वर टू इंप्रूव ईमेल डिलीवरी
एंड इंक्रीज द लाइकलीहुड दैट फिशिंग ईमेल
रीच द टारगेट इनबॉक्स इंस्टीड ऑफ स्पैम
फोल्डर। मतलब या फिर आप क्या करते हो अपना
खुद का कस्टम मेल सर्वर सेटअप करते हो
ताकि जो आपकी ईमेल्स हैं वो डायरेक्टली
इनबॉक्स में जाए ना कि किसी स्पैम फोल्डर
में ना कि उनके स्पैम फोल्डर में। इसके
लिए क्या करते हैं हम? इसके लिए फॉर दिस
अटैकर रिक्वायर ए स्ट्रांग अंडरस्टैंडिंग
ऑफ ईमेल ऑथेंटिकेशन ऑथेंटिकेशन
टेक्नोलॉजीस सच एज एसपीएफ
डीके आई एम या डीमार्क मतलब क्या है कि
आपको ऐसा करने के लिए आपके पास इन चीजों
की नॉलेज होनी चाहिए जो ईमेल के जो
ऑथेंटिकेशन टेक्नोलॉजी है उसके बारे में
आपको नॉलेज होनी चाहिए दूसरा आपको यह
कंट्रोल बायपास करने आने चाहिए अगर आप खुद
की इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर सेटअप कर रहे हो
अदरवाइज़ क्या होगे? आपका हमेशा मेल किस
में जाएगा? स्पैम में जाएगा। उसका कोई
फ़ायदा ही नहीं है। क्योंकि आपका टारगेट
उसको कभी भी पढ़ नहीं पाएगा। अब अगर अब हम
बात करें कि आपकी जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग है
वो हमेशा
कंप्यूटर पे नहीं होती या हमेशा जो आपका
पीसी है उसी के साथ नहीं होती। उसके अलावा
भी बहुत सारी चीजें हैं। जैसे कि हम दे आर
लॉट ऑफ या दे आर न्यूमरियस रियल वर्ल्ड
इंगेजमेंट्स आल्सो इनकरपोरेट फिजिकल रिकॉन
एंड टेक्निक्स। इसके अलावा भी हम क्या कर
सकते हैं? पीसी किसी पीसी के बजाय फिजिकल
रिकॉन टेक्निक का यूज़ कर सकते हैं। जिनमें
आती है आपकी डमस्टर ड्राइविंग। हम बात कर
सकते हैं डमस्टर ड्राइविंग का भी हम यूज़
कर सकते हैं। बहुत सारी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन क्या
करती हैं? वो फिजिकल रिकॉन या डमस्टर
ड्राइविंग जैसी टेक्निक भी इंक्लूड करती
हैं ड्यूरिंग पे टेस्टिंग। अब आप बोलोगे
आप सोच रहे होंगे सर
क्या सर हम इतनी पढ़ाई करके बनने तो एथिकल
हैकर आए हैं। पर क्या आप हमें हमसे कचरा
साफ करवाने वाले हो? क्या हम हमसे गार्बेज
कलेक्टर कलेक्ट करवाने वाले हैं? क्या हम
उनकी कंपनियां का कचरा साफ करने जाएंगे?
इतनी पढ़ाई करने के बाद भी क्या मैं
गार्बेज कलेक्शन करूंगा? यह सवाल आपके मन
में होगा क्योंकि
बिकॉज़ द रियलिटी इज दैट मेनी लार्ज
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस अनइटेंशनली एक्सपोज
वैल्यूुएबल इंफॉर्मेशन थ्रू पुअर डिस्पोजल
प्रैक्टिससेस। क्योंकि बड़ी-बड़ी जो
कॉर्पोरेट कंपनीज़ होती हैं, वह बहुत
केयरलेस होती हैं। और अनइटेंसली जाने
अनजाने में बहुत सारी वैलएबल इंफॉर्मेशन
को वो क्या कर देती है? डिस्पोज कर देती
है क्योंकि उनको जो कचरे में डायरेक्ट किस
टाइप की इंफॉर्मेशन डिस्पोज करनी है किस
टाइप की इन डिस्पोज नहीं करनी है अगर
डिस्पोज करनी है तो कैसे करनी है उसकी सही
से प्रैक्टिससेस नहीं पता उसके सही से
पॉलिसीज नहीं पता सही से उनको बताया नहीं
गया इसी वजह से क्या कर देते हैं वह
डायरेक्टली उस इंफॉर्मेशन को कचरे में
फेंक देते हैं एंप्लाइज समटाइ्स डिस्कार्ड
ओल्ड लॉग इन शीट्स इंटरनल ऑर्गेनाइजेशनल
क्लाइंट मीटिंग नोट्स, प्रोजेक्ट रोड
मैप्स एंड टेक्निकल डॉक्यूमेंटेशन विदाउट
सिक्योरली श्रेडिंग और डिस्ट्रइंग देम।
मतलब क्या होता है कि बहुत सारे एंप्लई
क्या करते हैं कि उनके जो पुरानी लॉगिन
शीट्स हैं या जो इंटरनल
टीम स्ट्रक्चर्स हैं या जो क्लाइंट मीटिंग
नोट्स हैं या प्रोजेक्ट के रोड मैप्स हो
गए या जो टेक्निकल डॉक्यूमेंट्स हैं, उनको
क्या करते हैं? वह डायरेक्टली क्या कर
देते हैं? कचरे के डिब्बे में फेंक देते
हैं। बिना उनको श्रेड या
बिना उनको श्रेड या डिस्ट्रॉय किए या तो
बिना जलाए या बिना उनको श्रेड किए क्या
करते हैं? डायरेक्टली
क्या कर देते हैं? उसको डिस्ट्रॉय कर देते
हैं। एंड फॉर एन अटैकर दिस सॉरी
डायरेक्टली उनको कचरे में फेंक देते हैं।
एंड फॉर एन अटैकर दिस डिस्कारेड मटेरियल
कैन बिकम एन एक्सट्रीमली वैल्यूुएबल
इंटेलिजेंस सोर्स। मतलब क्या हुआ? कि अब
एक अटैकर के लिए यह कचरा किसी सोने से कम
नहीं है। ठीक है? किसी सोने से कम नहीं
है। क्योंकि अगर मुझे इस कचरे में ऐसी कोई
इंफॉर्मेशन मिल जाए जिसमें मैनेजर का नाम
या उससे रिलेटेड कोई अदर डिटेल्स मिल जाए
तो जो मेरा प्रीेक्स्ट होगा वो 100%
बिलीवेबल हो जाएगा। जो 100% बिलीव
बिलीवेबल हो जाएगा मेरा प्रीटेक्स्ट। ओके?
वह इतना अह उस पे टेक्स्ट स्ट्रांग होगा
जिस पे क्या करेंगे? देखते ही कोई भी
एंप्लई उस पे क्लिक कर देगा। देखते ही कोई
भी एंप्लई उस पे क्लिक कर देगा। ओके? तो
नेक्स्ट आते हैं फेज फाइव पर। अब आते हैं
इस लाइफ साइकिल के नेक्स्ट फेज पर। दैट इज
योर डिटेक्शन फेस। आपका डिटेक्शन फज़ के
ऊपर।
अभी आप लोगों को लग रहा होगा कि
सब कुछ आपके हिसाब से चल रहा है।
इंप्लीमेंटेशन फ़ज़ आप इंप्लीमेंटेशन फ़ज़
क्या आपका? एग्ज़क्यूशन फेज़ था। एग्ज़क्यूशन
में देखकर आपको लग रहा होगा सब कुछ आपके
हिसाब से चल रहा होगा। डू यू थिंक
एवरीथिंग इज़ गोइंग अकॉर्डिंग टू योर
प्लान? आप लोग सोच रहे होंगे सब कुछ आपके
हिसाब से चल रहा है। जैसे आपने उनसे
मिलताजुलता डोमेन खरीद लिया। एक बहुत
बढ़िया से स्क्रिप्ट रेडी कर ली। फिशिंग
मेल भेज दी। बट रिमेंबर
बट एक चीज याद रखना गाइस कि यहां पर आप
अकेले नहीं हो।
यहां पर जो गेम खेल रहे हो आप ऑफेंसिव
वाला
यहां पर आप अकेले नहीं हो। बिकॉज़
एव्री कॉइन हैज़ अनदर साइड। क्योंकि
एक सिक्के के दो पहलू होते हैं। ठीक है?
किसी भी सिक्के के दो पहलू होते हैं। ठीक
है? और अब यहीं पर
सिक्के का दूसरा पहलू एक्टिवेट होता है।
सिक्के का दूसरा पहलू आता है। और दूसरा
पहलू क्या है? कि हियर यहां पर कंपनी के
डिफेंडर्स आते हैं। यहां पर क्या आते हैं?
कंपनी के डिफेंडर्स आते हैं। ठीक है?
जिन्हें हम ब्लू टीमर्स और
शॉक टीमर्स शॉक टीम भी बोलते हैं। मतलब
जैसे मैं आपको क्या बता रहा हूं कि आपको
अभी तक लग रहा होगा एग्जीक्यूशन फेज में
आने के बाद जब आपने अटैक स्टार्ट कर दिया
आपको लग रहा होगा कि सब कुछ आपके हिसाब से
चल रहा है। जैसा आप चाहोगे वैसा होगा। पर
ऐसी बात नहीं है क्योंकि डिफेंडर्स भी हैं
क्योंकि डिफेंडर्स भी है। डिफेंडर्स में
आपके ब्लू टीमर्स या आपकी शॉक टीम भी हैं।
मतलब मतलब क्या है कि वह आपका जो सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग एक्टिविटी है उसको रियल टाइम
में डिटेक्ट करने की कोशिश करेंगे और जल्द
से जल्द उस अटैक को मिटिगेट करने की कोशिश
करेंगे। जितना जल्दी हो सकेगा उसको
मिटिगेट करने की कोशिश करेंगे। इसलिए यहां
पर क्या है? आप अकेले खिलाड़ी नहीं हो।
जैसा मैंने बोला यहां पर एक और खिलाड़ी है
जो डिफेंसिव टीम है। दूसरी क्या है?
डिफेंसिव टीम भी आपके खिलाड़ी है। नाउ द
रियलिटी ऑफ़ अब बात करते हैं रियलिटी ऑफ़
फुल रेड टीम इंगेजमेंट। इन फुल रेड टीम
इंगेजमेंट। डिफेंडर्स आर नॉट इनफॉर्म्ड इन
एडवांस दैट ए टेस्ट इज़ बीइंग कंडक्ट।
क्योंकि जब भी फुल रेटिम इंगेजमेंट
परफॉर्म की जाती है तो डिफेंडर को पहले
नहीं बताया जाता कि यहां पर टेस्ट परफॉर्म
किया जाने वाला है या हम टेस्ट करने वाले
हैं। डिफेंडर को इस बारे में कभी भी नहीं
बताया जाता। फॉर देम इट इज जस्ट अनदर
नॉर्मल बोरिंग वर्किंग डे जस्ट लाइक एनी
अदर डे अंटिल सडनली देयर डैशबोर्ड स्टार्ट
लाइटिंग अप विद रेड अलर्ट्स। ठीक है?
डिफेंड उनके लिए जो डिफेंडर्स हैं उनके
लिए यह एक नॉर्मल बोरिंग वर्किंग डे ही
होता है। बाकी दिनों की तरह जब तक उनके
डैशबोर्ड पर कोई रेड अलर्ट ना आ जाए। एंड
दिस फेज मे लुक बोरिंग बट इट इज द
मोस्टेंट पार्ट। अभी आपको लग रहा होगा कि
यह फेज कितना बोरिंग है या यह फेज आपको
बोरिंग लग रहा होगा शायद। बट यह प्रोसेस
जो है आपकी डिटेक्शन फज़ सबसे मोस्टेंट
पार्ट है इस
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग असेसमेंट का। बिकॉज़ आवर
ऑब्जेक्टिव इज़ नॉट टू डिफेट देम। क्योंकि
हमारा ऑब्जेक्टिव ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को हराना
नहीं है। आवर ऑब्जेक्टिव इज़ टू मेक द
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन स्ट्रांग एनफ। सो दैट व्हेन
ए रियल डेंजरस ब्लैक हेट हैकर्स कम्स
टुमारो देयर सिस्टम ब्लॉक द अटैक एट द
वेरी फर्स्ट लाइन ऑफ डिफेंस। मतलब जब कल
को कोई भी एक रियल या कोई भी एक खतरनाक
ब्लैक हेट हैकर्स आए ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अंदर
तो कंपनी के जो सिस्टम्स हैं उसको फर्स्ट
लाइन ऑफ डिफेंस में ही क्या कर दें? ब्लॉक
कर दें। हमारा एम यह है। हमारा एम यह है
इस बारे में ट्रेंड करना ना कि कंपनी को
डिफिट करना। जैसे कि मैंने पहले आपको
बताया था रिकॉन फेज के बाद मैंने आपको
बताया था डिज़ एंड अप्रूवल फेज में कि आप
जब डिजाइन अप्रूवल फेज करोगे तो वहां
डिजाइनिंग टाइम में आपको आपको ऐसे अटैक
प्लान करना है कि ताकि आपको ब्लू टिमर्स
पकड़ लें। उससे फायदा क्या होगा? उससे
फायदा यह होगा
जो उनकी जो ट्रेनिंग लूप है वह कंप्लीट हो
जाएगा और मैंने आपको बताया था उनका जो
ट्रेनिंग लूप कैसे काम करता है क्योंकि
अभी तक उनके पास जो ट्रेनिंग लूप था वो
थ्योरिटिकल था लेकिन आप उसको जो
प्रैक्टिकली
टच अप करवा दोगे प्रैक्टिकली उसके बारे
में बता दोगे प्रैक्टिकली उसका एहसास दिला
दोगे प्रैक्टिकली उनको मतलब रियल टाइम में
दिखा दोगे कि आपने जो ट्रेनिंग ली है आपको
जो भी अवेयरनेस प्रोग्राम करवाए गए हैं।
आपके जो डिफेंसिव कैपेबिलिटीज है जब वह
रियल टाइम में आप वर्क करते हुए देखोगे तो
आपकी कैपिटी कैपेबिलिटी थ्योरिटिकल से
प्रैक्टिकल पे और भी ज्यादा बढ़ जाती है।
जिससे आपका कॉन्फिडेंस बढ़ता है।
ओके। तो अभी आते हैं हम फेज सिक्स पर
मेजरमेंट फेज। अब जब अटैक विंडो खत्म हो
गया, अटैक आपका खत्म हो गया। उसके बाद आता
है आपका डाटा एनालिसिस फेस। ठीक है? यह भी
आप ही का काम है। डेटा एनालिसिस फेस भी आप
ही का काम है। बिकॉज़ आप फेसिंग अटैक कर
रहे हो। डाटा एनालिसिस।
क्योंकि आप सिमुलेट कर रहे हो पूरे अटैक
को। डाटा एनालिसिस फज़ जिसको मेज़रमेंट फज़
भी बोलते हैं। ओके? दिस इज वेयर वी स्टॉप
मेकिंग अजमशन एंड स्टार्ट वर्किंग विद
एविडेंस। यह वो फेज है जहां पर जितना हमें
हमें अज्यूम करना था, जितना हमने इमेजिन
करना था, कर लिया। उसके बाद हम क्या करते
हैं? यहां यहां पर एविडेंस के साथ काम
करते हैं। अज्यूमशन हम बंद कर देते हैं।
एव्री ऑब्जरवेशन कलेक्टेड ड्यूरिंग द
इंगेजमेंट इज एनालाइज्ड एंड कन्व्टेड इंटू
मेजरेबल रिजल्ट। यहां पर कोई भी जो भी
ऑब्जरवेशन आपको मिली इंगेजमेंट के दौरान
उसको एनालाइज किया जाता है। उसके बाद उसको
रिपोर्ट में लिखा जाता है। उसको उसको
कन्वर्ट किया जाता है रिजल्ट में। जो भी
ऑब्जरवेशन थी उसका रिजल्ट एक फाइनल आउटपुट
निकाला जाता है। इंस्टेड ऑफ ऑफरिंग
ओपिनियंस वी डिलीवर द क्लाइंट कंक्रीट
मैट्रिक्स स्टैटिस्टिकल एविडेंस एंड
क्वांटिफायबल डेटा। हम यहां पर हवा में
बातें नहीं करते। यहां पर हम क्लाइंट को
पूरा कंक्रीट मैट्रिक्स या एग्जैक्ट
नंबर्स या एग्जैक्ट डाटा प्रोवाइड करते
हैं। क्योंकि बिकॉज़ बिजनेस लीडर्स एंड
एग्जीक्यूटिव मैनेजमेंट रिलाई ऑन हार्ड
डाटा टू इवैलुएट सिक्योरिटी पोश्चर एंड
मेक इनफॉर्म डिसीजंस। क्योंकि जो बिजनेस
लीडर्स होते हैं वो सिर्फ हार्ड डेटा को
समझते हैं। वो आपकी हैकिंग टेक्निक्स आपने
क्या किया? आपने क्या नहीं किया? कैसे
किया? कैसे नहीं किया? आपने ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
किया। आपने सोशल इंजीनियरिंग किया, सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग कैसे किया? उनमें उनका कोई भी
इंटरेस्ट नहीं होता। उनका इंटरेस्ट होता
है हार्ड डाटा में कि भैया कितना परसेंटेज
एग्जैक्ट नंबर वो चीजें आपको उनको बतानी
पड़ती है। इसके लिए हम क्या करते हैं? दिस
इसके लिए ड्यूरिंग दिस फेज वी टिपिकली
प्रिपेयर ए मैट्रिक्स डैशबोर्ड कंटेनिंग
थ्री क्रिटिकल परफॉर्मेंस इंडिकेटर। इसके
लिए हम क्या करते हैं? एक मैट्रिक्स
डैशबोर्ड तैयार करते हैं, तैयार करते हैं।
जिसमें तीन क्रिटिकल इंडिकेटर हम 100%
मेंशन करते हैं। सबसे पहले हम मेंशन करते
हैं ससेप्टिबिलिटी रेट जिसको वन इंडेक्स
बोला जाता है। उसके बाद एमटीडी एमटीटी
मीन टाइम टू डिटेक्ट। थर्ड वन है आपका
रिपोर्टिंग रेट एंड
या रिपोर्टिंग वेलोसिटी। ये चीज है आपकी।
ठीक है? यह हम चीजें इंक्लूड करते हैं। तो
इनके बारे में समझते हैं क्या-क्या होती
है। सबसे पहले हम बात करते हैं
ससेप्टिबिलिटी रेट। फॉर एग्जांपल
ससेप्टिव रेट में क्या हो गया कि हाउ मेनी
पीपल फेल फॉर आवर अटैक। कहने का मतलब क्या
है? कि कितने परसेंटेज लोग हमारी बातों
में फंस गए और उन्होंने लिंक पर क्लिक कर
दिया। फॉर एग्जांपल अगर कंपनी में 1000
एंप्लॉय हैं। ठीक है? और 300 लोगों ने उस
पर क्लिक कर दिया तो हमारा जो सक्सेसिव
रेट हुआ ससेप्टिबिलिटी रेट हुआ वो कितना
हुआ? 30% हो गया। वो कितना हो गया? 30% हो
गया। एंड अगर हम इंडस्ट्री स्टैंडर्ड की
बात करें। इफ दिस रेट इज अबव 10% दी कंपनी
इज इन द एक्सट्रीम डेंजर ज़ोन। इंडस्ट्री
स्टैंडर्ड के मुताबिक यह रेट अगर 10% से
ज्यादा है, 10% से ऊपर है, तो कंपनी एक
एक्सट्रीम डेंजर ज़ोन के अंदर है। बिकॉज़ ए
रियल हैकर नीड जस्ट वन क्लिक टू कंप्र
कंप्रोमाइज द एंटायर ऑर्गेनाइजर। क्योंकि
एक रियल हैकर को कंपनी तबाह करने के लिए
सिर्फ़ एक क्लिक की ज़रूरत होती है। ओके?
सिर्फ एक क्लिक की जरूरत होती है। तो एक
डाटा हम यह इंक्लूड करते हैं। दूसरा हम
टाइम टू डिटेक्ट मतलब मीन टाइम टू डिटेक्ट
एम टी डी
मतलब क्या होता है कि हमारा मतलब हाउ
लॉन्ग डिड इट टेक्स फॉर द ब्लू टीम टू गेट
द फर्स्ट अलर्ट और डिटेक्ट द मशियस
एक्टिविटी आफ्टर वी लॉन्च द अटैक?
हमारे अटैक ल्च करने के कितने मिनट या
घंटों के बाद
शॉक टीम को पहला अलर्ट मिला या उन्होंने
पहली मिलीशियस एक्टिविटी पकड़ी? फॉर
एग्जांपल अगर हमारा अटैक सुबह 9:00 बजे
लॉन्च हुआ था अगर और शॉक टीम ने उसको
दोपहर को 2:00 बजे पकड़ा तो एस्टीमेटेड
कितने घंटे लगे उनके रिस्पांस टाइम में? 5
घंटे लगे। उनका रिस्पांस टाइम क्या है? 5
घंटे। एंड फाइव आवर्स इन द रियल वर्ल्ड
मींस रसमवेयर हैज़ ऑलरेडी स्प्रेड अक्रॉस द
नेटवर्क। रियल वर्ल्ड में 5 घंटे का मतलब
है आपका जो रेंसम वेयर है वह पूरे नेटवर्क
में फैल चुका है या फैल चुका होगा। इसलिए
आपका जो गोल होना चाहिए विदिन 15 मिनट
होना चाहिए। विद इन 15 मिनट्स जो पॉसिबल
नहीं है जो पॉसिबल नहीं है क्योंकि आज भी
एडवांस है बट अभी भी चीजें
विद इन 15 15 मिनट नहीं होती रियलिटी है।
थर्ड वन इज़ रिपोर्टिंग रेट एंड वेलोसिटी
एंड आफ्टर रिसीविंग द फर्स्ट ईमेल हाउ
मेनी अलर्ट एंप्लॉय क्लिक द रिपोर्टिंग
रिपोर्ट फिशिंग बटन एंड हाउ क्विकली द
फर्स्ट रिपोर्ट अराइव्ड। कहने का मतलब
पहला ईमेल मिलने के बाद कितने अलर्ट
एंप्लई ने उसको
फेसिंग रिपोर्ट फेसिंग किया मतलब फेसिंग
रिपोर्ट किया और पहली रिपोर्ट आने में
कितना टाइम लेगा कि आपने फिशिंग एंप्लई
फिशिंग मेल भेज दिया। ठीक है? तो कितने
एंप्लई ने उसको रिपोर्ट की है और पहली
रिपोर्ट कब मिली? किसको? शॉक टीम को। एंड
दिस इज द मोस्ट पावरफुल मैट्रिक। इट शोज़
इफ पीपल आर नॉट जस्ट प्रोटेक्टिंग
देमसेल्व्स बट द एंटायर ऑर्गेनाइजेशन। और
यह मैट्रिक्स सबसे मजेदार मैट्रिक्स है
क्योंकि यहां पर हम देखना चाहते हैं कि
क्या लोग सिर्फ खुद के खुद को बचा रहे हैं
या कंपनी के बारे में भी सोच रहे हैं। फॉर
एग्जांपल 1000 एंप्लॉय थे। 450 ने रिपोर्ट
किया तो 45% रिपोर्टिंग रेट है एंड फर्स्ट
रिपोर्ट आई विद इन 7 मिनट मतलब इफ द
रिपोर्ट रेट इज अबव 40% दी कंपनीज़ ह्यूमन
फायर वाल इज स्ट्रांग मतलब इसका मतलब क्या
हुआ अगर रिपोर्टिंग रेट 40% से ज्यादा है
तो मतलब कंपनी जो ह्यूमन फायर वाल्स है वो
जो लोग हैं वह काफी अवेयर हैं। उन उनके
अंदर जो ट्रेनिंग करवाई गई है उनकी जो
अवेयरनेस ट्रेनिंग है या जो उनके जो
ट्रेनिंग मॉड्यूल है वो काफी स्ट्रांग है।
मतलब कंपनी पर अटैक आसानी से नहीं होगा।
ओके इफ द रिपोर्टिंग रेट इज अबव 40% द
कंपनीज़ ह्यूमन फायर वाल इज स्ट्रांग मतलब
वेरी स्ट्रांग। नाउ अब बात करते हैं फेज
सेवन। फेज सेवन क्या हमारा? रिपोर्टिंग
फेज। अब इसके बाद आता हमारा फाइनल फेज है।
कौन सा? रिपोर्टिंग फेज। नाउ ड्यूरिंग दिस
फेज ऑल कलेक्टेड एविडेंस इंक्लूडिंग
मैट्रिक्स, टाइमलाइंस, स्क्रीनशॉट्स,
ओसेंट फाइंडिंग्स, ऑब्जरर्वेशंस, टेक्निकल
एविडेंस इज कंप्लाइड इनू ए सिंगल वेल
स्ट्रक्चरर्ड प्रोफेशनल सिक्योरिटी
असेसमेंट रिपोर्ट। अब इस फेज में क्या
होता हमारे जितने भी नंबर्स हैं, जितनी भी
टाइमलाइंस है, जितने भी स्क्रीनशॉट है, जो
भी ओसेंट फाइंडिंग है, जो भी एविडेंस है,
जो भी ऑब्जरवेशन है, सबको हम एक जगह
कंपाइल करते हैं। कंपाइल करके एक रिपोर्ट
फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट करते हैं। कंपाइल करके
एक प्रोफेशनल रिपोर्ट फॉर्मेट में कन्वर्ट
करते हैं। एंड द ऑब्जेक्टिव इज टू
ट्रांसफॉर्म द रो डेटा जनरेटेड थ्रू आउट द
इंगेजमेंट इंटू एक्शनबल एक्शननेबल
इंसाइट्स दैट द ऑर्गेनाइजेशन कैन यूज टू
इंप्रूव इट्स सिक्योरिटी पोश्चर। हम क्या
करते हैं? इस सारे डेटा को जो इंगेजमेंट
के अंदर हमें मिला जो भी हमारी ऑब्जरवेशन
थी उसको हम क्या करते हैं? एक एक्शननेबल
फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट करते हैं ताकि इस डाटा
से जो ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस है वह अपने
सिक्योरिटी पोश्चर को अपग्रेड कर सके। सही
जगह पर इन्वेस्ट कर सकें। इट इज एसेंशियल
टू रिकॉग्नाइज दैट ए स्टैंडर्ड प्रोफेशनल
इंडस्ट्री रिपोर्ट इज यूजुअली ऑर्गेनाइज्ड
इनू टू मेन सेक्शंस।
अब एक चीज का ध्यान रखना कि कोई भी जो
स्टैंडर्ड या जो प्रोफेशनल इंडस्ट्री
रिपोर्ट होती है यूजली उसको दो मेन सेक्शन
में डिवाइड किया जाता है क्योंकि दोनों
सेक्शंस को पढ़ने वाले अलग-अलग लोग हैं।
जो दोनों सेक्शंस हैं वो उनको पढ़ने वाले
बिल्कुल अलग-अलग लोग्स हैं। क्योंकि एक
नॉन टेक है एक टेक है। तो सबसे पहले बात
करते हैं सेक्शन वन की बात करते हैं
जिसमें है एग्जीक्यूटिव लीडरशिप बिजनेस
स्टेक होल्डर्स या डिसीजन मेकर्स जिनको
चाहिए एक कंसाइज समरी
मतलब क्या रिस्क है ओल इंपैक्ट क्या हुआ
और क्या हमारे रेमडीएशंस है उनको आपके
अटैक पैटर्न से कोई मतलब नहीं आपने फिशिंग
किया वह किया यह किया उससे उन्हें कोई भी
मतलब नहीं है
कन्वर्सली टेक्निकल टीम्स इंक्लूडिंग
सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट सिस्टम
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स इंजीनियर्स उनको चाहिए
कंप्रहेंसिव टेक्निकल इंस टेक्निकल
डिटेल्स मतलब एक तो जहां पर है आपके सीईओ
सीएफओ सीटीओ सीओ आपके जो बिजनेस लीडर्स
उनको आपकी टेक्निकल रिपोर्ट से कोई मतलब
नहीं उनको एक समरी चाहिए क्या रिस्क था
एग्जैक्ट नंबर चाहिए ओवरऑल इंपैक्ट क्या
हुआ कितने करोड़ों लाखों का नुकसान हो
सकता था या होने वाला था या हो गया या फिर
उनको रेमडीएशन हमें कहां पर इन्वेस्ट करना
चाहिए दूसरे लोग हैं टेक्निकल टीम्स जहां
पर सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट हैं आपके सिस्टम
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स हैं आपके इंजीनियर्स हैं
जिनको चाहिए पूरी ईच एंड एव्री क्या
फाइंडिंग थी क्या-क्या एविडेंस हैं
क्या-क्या आपने कैसे अटैक किया कौन सा टूल
यूज़ किया क्या आईओसीस हैं और हमारे पूरे
पूरे डिटेल्स रिमडीिएशंस कि हमें
कैसे-कैसे क्या-क्या करना चाहिए ये सारी
चीजें। तो जैसे कि दो रिपोर्ट फॉर
एग्जांपल जहां पर टारगेट ऑडियंस क्या है?
एक तो एग्जीक्यूटिव समरी बनाते हो रिपोर्ट
में जहां पर सीएफओ बोर्ड डायरेक्टर हो गए।
जहां पर आप क्या मेंशन करते हो कि वहां पर
आपको ब्रेक
एक क्या करना पड़ता है आपको? वहां पर ये
एक कांसेप्ट मेंशन नहीं करता कि आपने सब
डोमेन एनुमरेशन किया, रिवर्स सेल किया।
आपको सिर्फ वहां पर बिजनेस इंपैक्ट की बात
करनी है। फॉर एग्जांपल आवर अटैक शो दैट
25% ऑफ एंप्लई लीक्ड क्रेडेंशियल्स व्हिच
मींस इफ दिस व रियल अटैक द कंपनीज़
फाइनेंसियल डाटा कुड बी कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड
एंड रिकवरी कुड कॉस्ट सेवरल लाख या करोड़।
मतलब यह है कि हमारे अटैक में 25% एंप्लई
ने क्रेडिट से लीक कर दिए। जिसका मतलब यह
है कि अगर यह अटैक रियल होता तो कंपनी का
फाइनेंसियल डाटा कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो सकता था
और इसकी रिकवरी में आपको इतने लाखों
करोड़ों रुपए लगते। अब यहां पर गोल क्या
है? गोल है टू हेल्प देम अंडरस्टैंड द
ओवरऑल सिक्योरिटी पोश्चर एंड वेयर दे नीड
टू इन्वेस्ट।
यहां पर क्या है कि हमें उनको यह समझाना
है कि उनका जो ओवरऑल सिक्योरिटी पोश्चर है
वह कैसा है और उन्हें कहां इन्वेस्ट करने
की जरूरत है। दूसरी
टेक्निकल रिपोर्ट जिसकी बात जहां पर क्या
है आपके नेटवर्क एडमिन होते हैं, शो
एनालिस्ट होते हैं, सिस्ट एडमिनस होते
हैं। वहां पर आपको क्या करना है? स्टेप
बाय स्टेप टेक्निकल ब्रेकडाउन मतलब कौन सा
टूल आपने यूज़ किया? कौन सा ईमेल सिंटेक्स
आपको मिला? किस एंप्लई ने क्लिक किया
रिवर्स सेल का स्क्रीनशॉट हो गया टाइमलाइन
क्या थी पेलोड आई पीज हेडर्स पूरी उनको
चाहिए अटैक चेन चाहिए आपने क्या कैसे किया
दूसरी सबसे बड़ा सेक्शन होता है इसमें
आपका रेमडीएशंस मतलब डिटेल्स एक्शन लेबल
फिक्सेस मतलब यहां पर आपको क्या करना है
रेमडीएशन पूरे डिटेल्स रेमिडीएशन का क्या
जैसे फॉर एग्जांपल व्हिच बाउंडेड फायर
वाल्स रूल्स टू ब्लॉक वि कस्टम एसपीएफ
डेकम फिल्टर्स मतलब फायरp आपको और कौन सा
नया रूल्स लगाने की जरूरत है यह अटैक
ब्लॉक करने के लिए या फिर ईमेल हेडर्स में
क्या आपको इंप्लीमेंट करना है क्या आपको
ईमेल गेटवे में पॉलिसी अपडेट करनी है या
क्या फ़्टर करने की जरूरत है या कितनी और
हार्डने की जरूरत है यह सारी चीजें आपको
क्या करने की जरूरत है एग्जजेक्टली उनको
बताने की जरूरत है एग्जजेक्टली उनको बताने
की जरूरत जरूरत है।
ओके
सबको समझ में आया
यहां तक सबको समझ में आया एवरीवन
यह था हमारा टॉपिक आज का। यहां तक सबको
समझ में आया?
तो आपको सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक लाइफ
साइकिल के बारे में पता चल गया।
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक लाइफ साइकिल
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? क्लियर है? कि चलो मुझे
बताओ। सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक लाइफ साइकिल
में टोटल कितने फेज हैं? जल्दी बताओ चैट
में कितने फेज हैं?
और कौन-कौन से जल्दी से टाइप करो चैट में
जो एक्टिव है जिनको पता है वह जल्दी से
टाइप कर देंगे जो क्लास में प्रेजेंट नहीं
थे जिनको नहीं पता तो फिर वो नहीं कर
पाएंगे जल्दी बताओ फटाफट चैट में कितने
टोटल फेज हैं और वह फेज कौन-कौन से हैं
देखता हूं कितने लोगों को पता है
कौन-कौन से बताओ
सातों फेजों के नाम टाइप करो जल्दी-जल्दी
फटाफट
विद इन 1 मिनट
वेरी गुड इवनिंग
आप लेट हो गए आज
बताओ जल्दी से या नहीं बताओगे?
जल्दी जल्दी बताओ चैट में अगर सात फेज हैं
तो सातों फेजों के नाम क्या हैं?
इट्स ओके। अगर आप लेट हो गए तो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है। कवर कर लेना। आज का टॉपिक छोटा
ही था।
स्कोप रिकॉर्ड डिजाइन इंप्लीमेंट डिटेक्शन
मेजर देन फाइनली रिपोर्ट। गुड।
बिल्कुल सही है। बिल्कुल सही है।
ओके तो अच्छी बात है। आप लोगों को पता है।
तो एक और चीज बताता हूं। नेक्स्ट क्लास
में जो क्लास 71 होगी उसमें हम पढ़ेंगे एक
और
टैक्टिक जिसको हम बोल सकते हैं या एक वो
बोल सकते हैं कि फेज टू को के ऊपर एक वो
है ओडी ओडी लूप उसके बारे में बात करेंगे।
ऑडियो लूप क्या है? ऑब्जर्व, ओरिएंट,
डिसाइड एंड एक्ट। इसके बारे में हम क्लास
71 में बात करेंगे।
इसके बारे में हम क्लास 70 में 71 में बात
करेंगे। ओके एवरीवन
ऑडियो लूप और एक केस स्टडी रियल वर्ल्ड
केस स्टडी।
तो बताओ क्लास में किसी को कोई डाउट?
वैसे 40 टू 45 मिनट की क्लास वैसे अच्छी
होती है ना जल्दी से फिनिश हो जाती है।
कंटेंट का कंटेंट कवर हो जाता है और आप
टाइम भी निकाल सकते हो। है ना?
तो किसी को कोई डाउट है रिलेटेड टू द
क्लास पहली बात तो व्यू ही नहीं है चले गए
सब क्लास छोड़ के आप दो ही हो
आप दो दो ही हो
तो अगर किसी को कोई डाउट नहीं है तो क्लास
को एंड करें फिर बताओ और अगर डाउट है तो
मुझसे पूछ सकते हो नेक्स्ट 1 मिनट में
ओके मोहित प्रजापति एंड ओके आप भी दोनों
कर नो प्रॉब्लम बस कवर कर लेना
ओके मेरा नेक्स्ट हमारे नेक्स्ट वीडियो का
आपको कैसे नोटिफिकेशन मिलता है आपको क्या
करना है ना आपको बता देता हूं आपको जाना
है डेफ्रोनिक्स आपको सर्च करना है सॉरी
YouTube पे जाना है वेट आई एम गोइंग टू
गाइस आपको जाना है YouTube पर। YouTube पे
जाके आपको क्या करना है? सर्च करना है
डेफ्रोनिक्स।
आपको सर्च करना है डेफोनिक्स।
ठीक है? डेफ़ोनिक्स पे क्लिक करोगे। यह आ
गया आपके डेफ़ोनिक्स एकडमी का YouTube
चैनल। तो यहां पर जाओगे क्लिक करो। क्लिक
करने के बाद जैसे हमारी क्लास कौन सी चल
रही है? 70 चल रही है। तो मैं आपको जैसे
यह हमारी 68 है आपकी ये सारी चीज़ आ गई। तो
मैं आपको 69 पे लेके जाता हूं जो हमारी
हुई थी। मैं इसको बंद कर देता हूं। लो यह
हमारी 69 क्लास थी। तो आपका जो
डिस्क्रिप्शन लिंक है डिस्क्रिप्शन में
आपको मिलेगा यह रहा जॉइन आवर WhatsApp
चैनल। तो जैसे यहां पर आप क्लिक करोगे तो
यहां पर आप क्या करोगे? डायरेक्टली
WhatsApp चैनल में डेफ्रोनिक्स aडमी के
WhatsApp चैनल में यहां पर आप ज्वाइन हो
जाइए। तो वहां पर क्या करना है? वहां पर
आपको सारे नोटिफिकेशन मिलते हैं। सारे
अपडेट मिलते हैं। रिलेटेड टू द अपकमिंग
क्लासेस या कोई कोर्स आने वाला है, कुछ भी
आने वाला है। सारी चीजें आपको यहां पर
मिलेगी। पता चल गया।
पता चल गया मोहित प्रजापति
ओके चलिए फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं एंड
बाय बाय गुड नाइट एवरीवन एंड सी यू फॉर
नेक्स्ट सेशन बाय गुड नाइट एवरीवन